business rates is a failing tax and it
is now solving growth and
apprenticeships in my own company i'm
going to have to downsize because of
business rates so what can you do to
help businesses on this front well i
think you're right to talk about the
long-term challenge let me say first of
all
for for for small businesses in my
constituency high levels of business
rates is a huge problem on the high
street what we've said we're going to do
uh
when we come in we're not going to have
the next cut in the main corporation tax
rate for large companies instead we're
going to use that money to cut business
rates by one percent and then freeze
them for a second year for any uh
business with a property which is less
than 50 000 pounds that's 1.5 million
properties in our country we think that
would give an average tax cut of 470
pounds to a small business that will
help lots of small businesses but it
doesn't solve the underlying problem and
so we also need to be thinking what are
we going to do if you think about
sainsbury's or
next big companies they're competing
against online retailers who may
actually have their
their their warehouses outside of
britain they can avoid paying business
rates and they're still competing and
the playing field isn't level so i think
it's right that we asked some big
questions for the long term about
whether or not there's a better way to
to uh to do this
at the moment the business rates system
was based upon a view of commerce which
is quite 20th century and we're in the
21st century now so could you could you
cut business rates or could you cut
something like v80 and what what there
isn't as i've said for small companies
will have a one percent cut and then
freeze through a year and that will help
1.5 small businesses immediately but for
the medium term we need to ask some big
questions the reality is it's expensive
and i've not got a big pot of money
obviously the deficit from george
osborne is going to be 90 billion pounds
and our nhs is in is under real pressure
so uh i've not got easy solution i think
we need to look hard at this the
government's announced a review but i
think some people feel the treasury are
using that to sort of stall the issue i
want to take this review seriously and
ask with business some big long-term
questions about the way which business
rates is working